breaking tonight there was no collusion
where's the media a bipartisan committee
of Senate Democrats and Republicans
found zero evidence of wrongdoing by the
Trump campaign now we're going to bring
you all the details coming up along with
several other important deep state
updates including now criminal referrals
finally for FISA abuse oh and other
people like on the left actually lied to
Congress too what will they get be
getting there pre-dawn raids with 27
people and amphibious vehicles full lawn
gear but first we need to tackle the
what is a garbage new compromised
supposedly surrounding border security
and tonight's Hannity watch on building
the wall and keeping the government open
so we have a bipartisan congressional
committee they have agreed to allocate a
whopping a one point three seven five
billion dollars for new border wall
construction
now that pales in comparison to the
President's request from five point
seven billion but would fund
approximately fifty five miles of new
wall construction on a border that is
two thousand miles long and we haven't
seen the language nor as the White House
sources are telling me that it's still
being worked out but if Democrats are
going to put a lot of restrictions on
wall construction in other words that
it's not really wall money this is not a
bill the president will be able to sign
the you'll then need a clean CR earlier
today here is how the president
responded to the initial details of this
new budget deal take a look have to
study I'm not happy about it it's not
doing the trick but I'm adding things to
it and when you end whatever I have to
add it's all it's all gonna happen where
we're gonna build a beautiful big strong
wall that's not gonna let criminals and
traffickers
drug dealers and drugs into our
functions very simple so I can tell you
that am i happy first glance I just got
to see it the answer is no I'm not I'm
not happy I'm not happy either nobody
should be happy the president has every
right to be angry
the so called compromise his typical of
the DC sewer and swamp and its level of
funding for security and safety the
American people is pathetic it's almost
as if lawmakers in Washington from the
comfort of their own of walled homes
they don't realize the horrors of sex
trafficking even young girls put into
prostitution human trafficking the drug
trafficking 90% of our heroin comes
across that southern border it occurs
every single day of every week of every
month of every year it's almost as if
they just don't care in the past two
years alone criminal illegal aliens have
been responsible for 100,000 assault
charges 30,000 sexual assault crimes and
4,000 murders and homicides says if they
don't care and that yesterday by the way
330 illegal immigrants including many
unaccompanied minors were apprehended
west of El Paso where there's no border
wall it's almost as if they don't care
about the angel moms and dads that we
have interviewed on this ferry show
children their kids senselessly taken by
people who crossed their lives taken by
people across these borders illegally
how many Democrats actually called any
of the families of these victims it
would be perfectly reasonable for
President Trump to reject this bill now
there's another solution maybe even a
better solution I'm not as concerned as
some other conservatives if the
president signs the bill but there's a
couple of ifs step one president decides
he wants to sign the compromise which
would guarantee the one point three
seven five billion dollar down payment
for the wall okay that money can be used
immediately now if he takes step two
which is the president utilizing money's
identified some nine hundred million
dollars for additional construction that
is already available for the
administration's discretion that would
be about two point three billion but the
important third step needs to
happen simultaneously and that would be
the president would need to declare a
national emergency this is the time that
is a necessity and the president I think
I know him pretty well telegraphed that
very thing just today you just heard him
indicate a coming plan that he would
find the other money's on top of
whatever Congress gives him that would
allow the administration to access
billions more in wall funding and by the
way the national emergency would be
challenged as we always see with the
Democrats that low judge shopping in
California or Oregon or Hawaii then
they'll go to the Ninth Circuit and then
because of all the constitutional issues
involved being number one an emergency
separation of powers the president's
role as our commander in chief I think
the president is on very firm legal
grounds given the national security
risks that are stemming from a porous
southern border and additionally the
president has even further authority
which the Supreme Court I'm sure would
look at and that would be a real law 10
USC 284 that gives the president in
other words the executive branch the
authority for the construction of roads
and fences and the installation of
lighting to block drug smuggling
corridors across international
boundaries of the United States now
despite what the haters on both sides of
the aisle are telling you remember
before 2016 I always shoot straight with
you I've known this president for over
two decades and I told everybody went
out on a limb and said he is going to
keep his promises and that he'd govern
as a conservative and that he would work
tirelessly to improve the country well
let's see the biggest tax cuts and a
burdensome regulation he's to
originalist on the Supreme Court yeah I
was right the haters the never Trump
errs were wrong and that's exactly what
he's done and I'm telling you right now
it's not gonna be any different with
securing our nation's borders he is
tenacious and he will fight to get that
wall built and guess what the vast
majority of the American people well
look at the CBS News poll they support
him 72% of Americans agree with the
president and his policies on
immigration and by the way some good
news breaking also tonight the
just tweeted quote was just presented
the concept and parameters of the border
security deal will be getting almost
twenty three billion for border security
regardless of what they give us meaning
Congress wall money it is being built as
we speak let me interpret that for
members of Congress and the hate Trump
media sounds like a national emergency
is going to be declared but I have no
insider information so Democrats have
agreed to over 1.3 billion dollars for
and billions by the way more for border
security and Democrats are now agreeing
to fund something by the way this is
amazing because they were for referring
to building walls as immoral just a
short time ago now they're funding these
immoral behaviors watch this we are
aghast that he wants this giant 30-foot
wall to be the symbol of America I tell
President Trump I've told him to his
face we want this symbol of America to
remain the Statue of Liberty freedom
equality not a divisive wall
I want support a wall I believe in
border security I think a wall is not a
smart way to make us safer is an
immorality it's not who we are as a
nation Chuck Schumer and all the
Democrats supported that wall in the
second term of Barack Obama
but now the Trump wants it they can't
support anything Trump wants notice that
old bozo will Roarke down and El Paso
actually said that walls make us less
safe and end lives wow maybe someone
should warn Americans about the serial
killer walls making us less safe less
safe today thank you bozo for your
important input in your warning but
guess what it gets even more absurd many
on the Left have recently referred to
border security efforts as racist watch
this foundation of the wall is hate it's
fear becomes fear of the other and then
it becomes fear
Brown people and it becomes fear of
caravans in fear of invasions in fear of
ms-13 blatantly attempt to stir up fear
of people of color of brown people now
has nothing to do with the fact that
many Americans have been murdered in the
sexual assaults and there's you know all
sorts of violent assaults and heroin
ninety percent of it coming into our
country and we have an opioid epidemic
really we're gonna play the race card
here and I'll great you ninety-eight
percent of the people across that border
illegally just want a better life that
which we take for granted as Americans
but playing politics with safety
security even life and death well that's
just the tip of the iceberg in terms of
America's now radical extreme new
socialist democratic party kind of like
when Senator Bob Menendez was scolding
the president for criminalizing illegal
immigrants who actually drink and drive
watch this the president's
zero-tolerance policy that has turned
everyone regardless of their record into
a criminal for example if you cross the
border undocumented he has now made you
a criminal he is creating that problem
by turning people away who legitimately
seek asylum if a person has a driving
while under the influence violation he
is now making that saying that that's a
criminal if they come in illegally they
broke the law by the way it's part of
the dumbest thing I've ever heard
drunk drivers killed people every day
senator maybe talk to mothers against
drunk driving or talk to a parent who
has lost the child killed by a drunk
driver you know for the Democrats this
is all one big political game life and
death safety security these people need
to meet these angel moms and dads and
kids killed by drunk drivers they really
need an intervention sadly the only
thing they care about is keeping the
government open making the president
look bad even denying daca and dreamers
things they say they want and helping
furloughed employees know nothing
Trump's hating Trump the president
a life-and-death battle Democrats are
fighting for virtually nothing here
except that which they supported a
couple of years ago the president now
has rightly made protecting our nation's
borders and preserving American life his
number one priority we all know the
statistics radical socialist Democrats
they're calling Walz immoral they now
advocate even for infanticide during the
birth process nine months into pregnancy
calling for a ban of most forms of
electricity the lifeblood of our economy
fossil fuels pushing an end to the
consumption of meat because cows and
flatulence and yeah being associated
with some of the most bigoted hateful
anti-semites in the country this party
Democratic extreme radical socialist
party is a real-life dumpster fire it's
unfolding before our eyes I told you
this would happen and tonight by the way
we start with our Hannity watch on these
extreme socialists and of course
starting with congresswoman Alexandria
Cassio Cortes and her insane green New
Deal being supported by some of the most
prominent Democrats in her party last
night President Trump called them out in
a huge way
let's take a look they introduced a
massive government takeover that would
destroy our incredible economic gains
they introduced the so-called green New
Deal
[Applause]
it sounds like a high school term paper
that got a low mark it would shut down
American energy which I don't think the
people in Texas are gonna be happy with
that
foxnews.com a new article this evening
even left-leaning union leaders they're
now warning that this green New Deal
will lead to poverty they would like to
work and provide for their families and
let's not forget that 2020 candidate
senator Spartacus himself Cory Booker
quickly threw his support behind
socialist congresswoman Alexandria Casio
cortezes absurd green New Deal which
calls for an end to all fossil fuels oh
we're going to eliminate airplanes and
we're gonna have high-speed rail
how are you gonna get to Europe
Australia New Zealand trucks even
banning cows okay they've lost their
minds and booked her by the way who is
an admitted vegan get this I don't make
this stuff up either he's trying to
justify this insanity this platform
telling a vegan magazine this world
cannot sustain people eating meat only
rich people he talks about eating meat
Democrats really trying to take a White
House on a platform of banning meat
airplanes fossil fuels oh and rebuilding
every house in America the same party
that is now for infanticide the same
party that won't stand up - what
happened - I believe Oh even sexual
assault allegations and a rape
allegation if it's a member at their own
party many of them won't say I believe
now don't take my word for it in the
case of Booker he recently compared
tackling the scourge of cow flatulence
and other forms of carbon pollutants to
our efforts during World War two this
would be a joke but they're serious so
lock your freezers save your meat now
you may need it it'll be very valuable a
great investment for years to come and
now even Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell rightly planning to put other
Democrats on record he wants a vote on
the green New Deal
good goin Mitch I want to see if it
passes let's see what the Democrats vote
here because it will tell you everything
on paper just how radical and extreme
the Socialist Party has now become
rampant socialism which guarantees Oh a
job a vacation housing health care Oh
it'll take away your private
and everything else that it promises to
do whether you're willing or unwilling
to work is not only concerning ideology
in the rise of the Democratic Party now
another scary form of extremism is not
going away and that is the rise of
anti-semitism in the halls of Congress
recently far-left democratic
congresswoman Omar made a series of
disturbing anti-semitic tweets while
spreading an anti-israel conspiracy
theory apologising only for that one for
offending Jewish people but she's
retaining her position get this on the
Foreign Affairs Committee President
Trump tonight calling on her to resign
but known anti-semite Linda Sarsour
remember her she's rushing to
congresswoman Omar's defense no surprise
there Linda Sarsour is a friend to
Kirsten Gillibrand running for president
we're gonna keep you posted on the
bigotry of the left every single night
and hold these people accountable and
we'll have our Hannity watch regularly
now we turn to some other breaking news
tonight President Trump tweeted a big
thank you to conspiracy theory TV MSNBC
who was forced to come clean about their
Russia collusion conspiracy theories
which they've been peddling for two
straight years
when's that apology coming take a look
after two years and interviewing more
than 200 witnesses the Senate
Intelligence Committee has not uncovered
any direct evidence of a conspiracy
between the Trump campaign and Russia
that's according to sources on both the
Republican and the Democratic side of
the aisle if and when the President as
he may inevitably do point to this
reporting point to these conclusions and
say look the Senate Intelligence
Committee found that I am not guilty of
conspiracy he would be correct in saying
that well except except that the use of
the term not guilty was not really
appropriate because that they're not a
court of law
that said Trump will claim vindication
through this and he will be partially
right that's right you heard it right
the bipartisan Senate committee
Republicans and Democrats investigating
campaign fraud no evidence of Trump
Russia collusion none including
Democrats and they have seen everything
Muller is seen
we've been telling you this for months
and months of months the left have been
force-feeding with hysterical coverage
the American people a steady diet of
insane bizarre lying conspiracy theories
every night just to remind you take a
look what do you got hard well Chris
yeah Chris unfortunately I can't go into
the evidence that's a big you can't
reveal you know I can't reveal that
Chris
certainly say with confidence that there
is significant evidence of collusion
between the campaign and Russia Vladimir
Putin and his associates somebody has
something on Donald Trump as we are
looking at the possibility that the
President of the United States and those
around him during an election campaign
colluded with a hostile foreign power to
undermine the basis of our democracy
it's so obvious that they were eager to
collude with Russia now we're seeing the
evidence that there was a conspiracy to
cover up this is evidence of willingness
to commit collusion there's outright
treason I mean there is no question that
what he is doing is giving aid and
comfort to the enemy is there any
evidence of collusion that you have seen
yet is there well there is a lot of
smoke we have no smoking gun at this
point now we have a lot more coming up
including criminal referrals on FISA and
the lying to Congress except maybe this
time the pre-dawn raid will be at a
Democrats house